nous avons ici un produit que nous
apportons nous diffusons en europe qui
est une chenillette tout-terrain la
distribution de matériel destiné à
l'accessibilité des personnes en
situation de handicap en france et en
europe la spécialité de l'entreprise ac
sol installée depuis novembre 2010 neuf
sur ce site de 2500 m² à trappes
on avait besoin à la fois de d'agrandir
les espaces de bureaux et de show room
pour recevoir nos clients mais également
toute la surface de stockage est un
troupeau
l'idée c'est d'anticiper le
développement futur d'avoir une marge de
gier a une marge de progression sans
avoir à bouger
jean-paul mignard a créé cette société
en 2010 d'abord dans son garage il
s'installe ensuite dans des locaux à
plaisir aujourd'hui ils sont quinze
salariés réalise environ 2,2 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires rampe
d'accès dispositif pour monter les
escaliers plateforme élévatrice des
produits importés et stockés dans ce
nouvel entrepôt plus grand que l'ancien
ça me facilite grandement la vie ne
serait ce que pour les inventaires qui
sont heureusement plus fiable de parle
la possibilité d'arrangements de
l'entrepôt où les choses sont bien
définis à des endroits clarinette
après avoir déménagé on a réussi à tout
bien définir les jeunes de location les
zones de pièces détachées les zones de
stockage de picking et puis de
l'étiquetage et du zonage d'entrepôt
pour savoir où et roger quoi dans sa
stratégie d'implantation axle a aménagé
un espace de coworking du mobilier une
connexion internet et une salle de
réunion avec une zone de l'entrepôt pour
du stockage mises à disposition pour des
entrepreneurs
ça me paraît tout à fait naturel après
avoir moi développer mon entreprise et
on a encore beaucoup de choses à faire
d'accompagner des jeunes créateurs ou
repreneurs d'entreprise avec une
croissance moyenne de 30% par an axle
vise les 2,5 millions d'euros en 2020
avec à l'horizon le développement de
projets autour des jeux olympiques de
paris en 2024